in early 2001
bethany mclean
at the time a writer for fortune
magazine
asked the question in an article
how does enron
make its money
reporting along with others
who wrote articles
led to a lot of inquiries that were put
to the enron management
within a few months the company was
bankrupt
bethany mclean's subsequent 2003 book
titled the smartest guys in the room
became a bestseller
next
successful documentary
since 2008 mclean has made a career of
writing about american financial crises
in january she discussed her reaction to
the
theranos saga
in an essay about convicted felon
elizabeth holmes she wrote quote for
those who believe she was guilty of a
great crime
it's a disappointing verdict
end quote
bethany mclean you recently wrote an
essay about the elizabeth holmes verdict
why
well the new york times came to me and
asked if i'd be willing to write an
essay when when the verdict came out and
i thought yes because it tapped into a
bunch of things that i had been mulling
over in the back of my mind and they're
two thoughts that don't necessarily
relate although i tried successfully or
not to pull them together in in the
piece but one is whether penalties
against white-collar criminals um
penalties against cases of business gone
wrong whether they really serve as a
deterrent um or not
and i've thought about that since
a piece i did in the wake of the enron
verdicts back in 2006 when jeff skelling
and ken lay were found guilty and
my co-author on the book i did about
enron uh wrote a piece for fortune and
the gist of the piece was everything's
different now the world is going to be
different executives are on notice that
they can't engage in the kind of
behavior that's right that's
manipulating the rules that's right up
against the line that's deceptive even
if the law sort of permits it and
everything's going to be different going
forward and of course this was summer
2006 where the events that caused the
financial crisis were already already
underway and uh it did nothing to change
that um financial crisis hit really in
in the fall of 2007. a year later so i
started to think huh if everything was
supposed to be different why wasn't
wasn't it different
and then the other thought that i have
started to mull over is this connection
between visionaries and fraudsters
what's really the difference between the
two and i you would you would think that
they exist on opposite ends of the
spectrum as far away from each other as
they could be but i started to decide
they are actually where the ends of a
circle meet and that one could become
the other pretty pretty easily because
some of the characteristics of each at
least when it comes to stories of
business gone wrong to white collar
fraud actually are quite similar
there's very rarely the case of a story
of business gone wrong where the
executive actually set out to rip people
off
what did you think of the verdict
so i was surprised by it even though the
gist of my piece was
that these verdicts don't necessarily
have larger meanings because of because
of some of the factors i just i just
talked about i
had actually thought that she would be
found guilty of defrauding patients and
not guilty of defrauding investors and i
suppose like a lot of us my
thoughts and hopes about the verdict
hinged on reflect my own bias i
believe that any investor who put money
into theranos without getting audited
financial statements and she which she
and theranos would never provide audited
financial statements
deserves to be ripped off that's just a
ridiculous thing to do
on the other hand patients are not
supposed to have to investigate the
validity and viability of their blood
test provider you're not supposed to
have to go to walgreens and find out
who's providing your blood test and make
sure that they're reputable and that
they're
actually doing what they said what they
said they were so the standard is
different for for both and the jury the
jury found the opposite they found her
guilty of the frauding
but but not guilty of defrauding
patients
our guest is bethany mclean on elizabeth
holmes and theranos
so break break it down for those who
haven't paid attention to the details uh
theranose
what kind of a company does it still
exist what did it do
so theranose uh was founded by a woman
named elizabeth holmes and the whole
idea of the company was that you could
revolutionize blood testing instead of
having to do this big draw from your
vein you know when you go into your
doctor's office and you have the the
syringe or needle put into your vein and
you watch the vials of blood filling up
and you think ah
the idea was that instead you could just
do a single finger prick and off that
little tiny bit of blood you could run
every test that a patient needed and so
the idea was this would be less of a
hassle for patients who are afraid of
needles but also that it would make the
whole process so much easier because you
could do this let's say a walgreens or a
grocery store and therefore would be
really good for people's health because
they would you would you would make
something easy and instantaneous that
had been difficult and expensive and
required a trip to the doctor's office
and so she this idea that she could
revolutionize this important area of
medicine that's used in all sorts of
diagnostics from you know thyroid issues
to hiv to
anything you you name it blood blood
draws our incredible incredibly
important diagnostic tool uh that she
could revolutionize this and in the
process make make a ton of money and it
turned out um and it started to unravel
when the wall street journal ran um some
detailed investigative stories basically
saying the technology didn't work
and she was instead of running all the
tests on this machine she'd invented
called the edison that that
that symposium that that could that
could analyze this tiny drop of blood
they had actually paradise had actually
jerry rigged um testing equipment from
other established companies uh in order
to basically pretend that they that that
they could do it and so she was
eventually charged with fraud both for
lying to patients about her technology
and um with she raised i think 900
million dollars from investors and for
raising lying to investors about the
money that theranos was making and the
promise of its technology
she's going to be 38 in february
how old was she when she started with
all this
i think she was 20 when she started the
company she was quite young and that
really fit in
i mean 10 years ago maybe even maybe not
10 years ago 20 years ago if you had
said that a 20-year-old who didn't
graduate from college and had no
experience in medicine no experience
building technological
equipment of any kind was going to
revolutionize something as complicated
as blood blood testing and it is very
complicated a lot of people have tried
to do this in in the past people would
have been like oh my god that's
ridiculous but you know in the frenzied
environment that we were in in the in in
the past decade it seemed obvious of
course young people are smarter than old
people of course young people without
any experience and any um
any bone feeds about about what they can
do of course they're better than an old
person with experience who may know what
they're talking about and so people just
lined up to to get to give her money and
i think some of it was also it was a
reflection of just how much money there
there was and i don't have the numbers
at my fingertips but the amount of
money to fund startup companies has just
exploded uh over the last 15 or 20 years
and then part of it was that she tapped
into this moment when silicon valley was
starting to ask questions or
said more accurately a lot of people
were starting to ask questions of
silicon valley about the total lack of
diversity that most people who get
funded are are white men
and elizabeth tapped into this desire to
see a a woman do well in the world
and i think that helped her raise just
an extraordinary sum of money
back in 2003 you wrote a book called the
smartest guys in the room
that became a successful documentary
you originally wrote an article for
fortune magazine
uh
did that article
trip everybody's
switch that led to the bankruptcy
no i really don't
think it did um and i think there's two
reasons for that the article actually
didn't get a ton of attention when it
when it came out it was only after
unbronzed bankruptcy that people looked
back and said why didn't anybody ask
questions and then people said oh look
some somebody did and so i think it's
one of those rare times in life where
you get too much credit for something
because in the end and this is part of
the reason that i don't think the
article caused or precipitated and runs
bankruptcy in the end while i asked a
lot of questions about how enron made
its money i didn't actually expose what
was really going on under under the
surface there um and so i think of the
story is more of a red flag rather than
uh she broke the story and and some i
think it takes more than what i did to
get people to say especially about a
really really
well-loved and admired company it takes
more than what i did to get people to
start to start second-guessing
but the other reason i think that the
article didn't cause and runs bankruptcy
is that i really picked up on a lot of
skepticism that was brewing about imran
i didn't cause it i had sources who were
saying even though they weren't on the
record who were saying there are a lot
of problems here and after the fact
after i announced bankruptcy when i did
the reporting for my book i found out
there were a lot of people raising
questions and
a lot of people who are skeptical of
enron and so i think i picked up on that
under i think i picked up on that
underlying skepticism and it's it's an
interesting point worth highlighting
about the difference between the world
then and the world now because in the
world then people who are skeptical
mainly short sellers people who bet that
a stock is going to decline weren't
public they didn't they didn't have a
forum in which to express themselves
publicly and many didn't so it was as if
even in a world that was supposedly
awash in information it's as if there
were these two separate spheres that
didn't touch each other and one was the
sphere of publicly available information
which was all enron is fantastic the
stock is going to double these guys are
petropreneurs they're the brilliant
they're the smartest guys in the room
and then the other circle was a circle
of very quiet people saying amongst
themselves this this company's a fraud
there's something there's something
really really wrong here and that's very
different today mainly due to the advent
of twitter
if you want to find out what skeptics
think about a company all you have to do
is look it's right there
the interesting thing is that doesn't
really change anything in in some ways
but um but i i
that is one good way in which social
media has has changed the world um i
think
well the reason i ask you this um is
because i wanted you to talk about the
role of the journalist
back when you did the article on enron
and then was it a journalist that
tripped again
the the switch on the whole story around
elizabeth holmes
yes so i think the role of a journalist
is what it's always been which is to
look at things with a skeptical eye to
listen to all sides of of a story and to
try to expose things that that that are
in the public's interest to to to to be
exposed i don't think the role of a
journalist has has has changed at all
i think that um
the guy who wrote the pieces at the wall
street journal john kerry wrote i think
he
i think his his pieces were more of the
classic breaking of the story than my
pieces about and enron were you know he
he really got inside the company he had
whistleblowers inside the company who
said this this technology doesn't
doesn't work um so i think in the end
his work was deeper than mine was i
didn't have whistleblowers inside and
ron who are saying this this this is a
problem this thing is about to explode
um so i i don't think the role has
changed i think the execution i'd give
him more credit than i'd give myself for
for breaking for breaking the story i
think i think that's different um i
think the ability to do that kind of
work has has has changed although
not not necessarily for for
for someone in john kerry's position he
was a wall street journal the wall
street journal like the new york times
still offers a lot of support to big
investigative projects uh that's much
harder to do today than it than it used
to be when i wrote about enron i was at
fortune magazine and you know it was
still the golden age of magazine
journalism and fortune was still part of
time inc which still existed which was
still one of the world's most powerful
magazine companies and i could have
taken the month or two that i spent on
the unrun story and if it hadn't panned
out if we had decided that i'd gone down
a rabbit hole and it didn't work it
wouldn't have been a problem i mean if i
had done ten of those in a row would
have been a problem but if you if if you
if you tried to investigate something
and it didn't work out you were safe
right or you still got paid you still
had a career it wasn't and i think the
pressure on journalists to execute in
the short term is much higher now than
it used to be at most places our guest
is bethany mclean on elizabeth holmes
and theranos first time i interviewed it
was 2005 and i bring that up because
your life has changed somewhat since
then you were married divorced and
remarried and
you have a couple kids now and how old
are they
i do i have a 10 and a 12 year old
and where do you live
i live mostly in chicago although i have
a apartment in new york as well and
spend some time there and what does your
husband do
uh well maybe if this isn't live maybe
we can cut it so i'm divorced again um
um but my husband was uh was a
prosecutor and is now a defense lawyer
ex-husband was a prosecutor he's now a
defense lawyer there how's that
so but the reason i asked this question
is how has your view i mean i was gonna
i'm gonna quote to you what you told me
in 2005
uh
and i wanted you to just tell me has
your life changed and how do you think
about this stuff you said in 2005 i've
become more cynical about corporate
america
and then later on you say to me i wasn't
cynical enough
so where's the cynicism and how is your
view of life and corporations and
whether or not we're getting a fair
shake on this change over the last uh 15
years
you know i think
i think unfortunately i've become more
cynical still and i would like to give
you a different answer than that but i
will offer a little bit of a caveat and
maybe a ray of hope
at the end of what i'm what i'm about to
say but i think even when we spoke
although i was a little i was more
cynical i still
didn't fundamentally question whether
capitalism itself in this country had
gone off the rails i think i still saw
enron as uh
as an example of what can go wrong but
as an outlier i didn't see it as
fundamentally indicative of a flawed
system
and i've over the last 15 plus years
i've spent a lot of time covering
additional stories of business gone
wrong and i've really begun to question
some of the fundamental tenets of our
system
i think the financial crisis for me was
was was a really big wake-up call
um
because it people think of enron in the
financial crisis is very different and
run was a fraud the financial crisis was
you know a bunch of companies who got a
little crazy about sub-prime mortgages
but we're really not that they're really
not that different and we we obviously
bailed out the system in in in the wake
of the financial crisis and there are a
lot of other examples we could go into
over over the last decade and
i started to think that these issues we
have of particularly of of crony
capitalism um
of rules that enable the rich to
continue to get richer are are really
problematic and let me be clear i have
nothing against somebody who invents a
business and provides jobs to lots of
people making a fortune that's i i am a
believer in that type of of capitalism
so i think i've become
i become a little more cynical because i
started to fundamentally question things
not just say oh here's an isolated
example of how things went wrong on the
flip side and a little bit of i guess
the ray of hope i i mentioned also met a
really a lot of really good people and a
lot of businesses that are run well and
run run run right and a lot of people
who are thinking deeply about about
these issues so
so i don't think it's all darkness our
guest is bethany mclean on elizabeth
holmes and fairness
i i want to i wrote down a as i was
thinking through the theronos situation
i wrote down a bunch of different people
uh that were around this story and
wanted to get your take
on what role they played and let's start
with the fact that some very big names
betsy devos rupert murdoch the walton
family the cox family invested in
theranos
and at the same time
well-known people became on their board
i mean the list is really as you know
quite interesting george schultz
who died last year at age 100
gary ruffhead the former chief of naval
operations on the board of tharnos
william perry former secretary of
defense in the clinton years
sam nunn united states senator from
georgia
jim mattis who was secretary of defense
during the trump administration henry
kissinger
dr william frist who is the former
majority leader republican in the united
states senate from tennessee heart
surgeon lung surgeon
we i'm not sure i pronounce this right
william fogey or
you can tell me how it is a former
director of the uh cdc
and riley bechtel big name chairman of
the board of the bechtel group where
george schultz was for a while they were
all on the board
right they got a
fifty thousand dollars a year which as
you know today is not very much money on
some of these boards where they get paid
four and five hundred thousand
so what were they what good is a board
if they missed all this
so let's start with the investors
because i think i have a shorter answer
for the investors and my answer about
the board would be it will be a bit
longer but so with the investors as i
said at the start of this i have very
little sympathy for them if you are a
big wealthy investor you're supposed to
be able to do the kind of due diligence
you're supposed to ask the sort of
questions that would have led you not to
put any money in into theranos uh a
really basic fact fairness wouldn't
provide audited financial statements so
every financial projection they provided
investors was just woo
and there were um for lack of a better
description and there were other people
sometimes i wonder if having kids has
permanently diminished my vocabulary
such that i use words like but that's
that's an aside anyway um
but there were people who didn't put
money into fairness precisely because
she wouldn't provide audited financial
statements and that was just that that
was that was that was um definitive for
them they just said no
we're not we're not doing it um one of
the documents that theron has provided
to investors was a document that made it
look like pfizer among other companies
had endorsed its technology so if you're
a big investor doing due diligence on
theranos one of the first things you
should do is pick up the phone and call
pfizer as it turned out at the trial
pfizer's pfizer decided the technology
was being s and they weren't going to do
any work with with their news it would
have taken a phone call not not much
more and so i don't have a lot of
sympathy for these big investors who
lost money they were victims of their
own desire to get rich their own greed
their own willingness to believe there's
a great line from this book about a con
man in the 1920s who is known as the
jackal of wall street and it says about
people who fall for scams their own
willingness to fall for it is to fall
for this fall for it is basically what
sends some smack into the into the setup
and it's and and that's true without
people's willingness to be deluded um
because of greed because of the fear of
missing out uh a lot of these financial
scams simply simply wouldn't happen so
that's the investors the board there's
there's some of that i have a little
more
it's funny when i wrote my book smartest
guys in the room i had i was very hard
on everyone's board and i've come to
have um and partly through a friendship
with one of the former board members
i've come to have a more
nuanced view of
of boards because i think they're in a
very difficult situation and one of my
favorite quotes is an f scott fitzgerald
quote and i use it often but it it
basically is that the true mark of
genius is being able to hold two
competing notions in your mind at the
same time and not go crazy and if you're
going to join a company's board then
it's not because you think the companies
the fraud and the executives are are
idiots you're joining the board because
you believe in this thing right and so
you have to be able to hold your belief
in
in the company with your willingness to
be skeptical and ask hard questions at
the same time
and that's even more complicated if you
don't have the background that would
enable you to ask hard questions as many
of the people most of the people on
theranosis board did
and in the end the fact that people
didn't have the right background there
there wasn't
somebody from a technology background
who had worked on blood draws before
there there wasn't a doctor who would
who had studied this for decades and in
the end the fact that her board
consisted of these big names with
political power um perhaps should have
been a warning sign to investors because
why didn't she have a board of people
who were equipped to understand what her
technology could do
and what the limitations and what the
right what what the right questions were
to ask so it is somewhat on her board
members and on any board members
um
you know if you're going to join a board
you should have some understanding or
there should you should make sure there
are other people on the board who have
an understanding of what
of what limitations the company is up
against and if there aren't any um and
you don't yourself understand it then
perhaps that should be a big
a a big red flag
um so that's why i'm a little bit more
nuanced on on on on the board but they
they they were suckered too because they
were willing to be suckered
but
if i'm an investor i'm talking about a
stock investor in that company i look at
that board and say they're they have a
fiduciary responsibility
to keep watch on what's going on how
these are big names
you can't get any bigger than george
schultz or gary ruff head or
bill perry or sam nunn jim mattis henry
kissinger william frist
and
how did she how did she buffalo them
were they paying any attention at all
and how much of this goes on in other
corporations that you've studied
so i think i think they
in in some ways for a good reason right
here's this young attractive blonde
woman who's promising to revolutionize
the world i think it made them feel good
about themselves to be supporters of of
her
and i think that was an important
element of how
they diluted them
themselves into not not asking tough
questions and that that stems from a
sort of good impulse right uh there's
there's there's nothing more to aim well
there probably are more dangerous things
but one very dangerous thing in the
world is when something makes you feel
really good about yourself like you're
like you're doing good and i think that
was that was that was part of part part
of the story here i think it was the i
the attraction of being part of
something that was going to change
change the world that was going to make
a big difference in people's lives
because of the easy availability of
of blood tests
i don't i think you would have to and
thus far
nobody on the board even at the trial
has been willing to be really really
candid about why they they got it wrong
and i think those would be really
interesting interviews if people were
willing to say
here's here's why i believe here's why i
didn't ask tough questions my guess is
the answer would be similar but slightly
different in in all cases but but but
yes i think to your point it that that
story has played out again again and
again um one of the one of the bits that
came out in trial testimony in theranos
was where a very
sophisticated hedge fund said to another
hedgehog look at these board members
wowza
speaking of an articulate language but
whatever
but because because the board was so
impressive and investors do look to that
and and they say oh look look at these
people who have signed off on this and
it has played out in other stories one
of the um other big corporate calamities
of the last decade was a company called
valiant that ended up not going bankrupt
but lost i think around 100 billion
dollars in market cap and what it turned
out valiant was doing was taking drugs
that were needed to save people's lives
and raising the price on them to
whatever the market would bear um and
making its profits in in large part
in substantial ways that that way and a
lot of people invested in valiant
because the other investors who were
involved a guy named bill ackman a
really well regarded hedge fund called
value act another really well regarded
investment fund called sequoia and so
people said oh i don't have to do my
homework look at these people who have
done their homework i'm just going to
get a free ride with with them and i
think that does speak to the limits of
ever outsourcing your due diligence
ever thinking that because another smart
person says something is right therefore
it's it's right because those smart
people could have different incentives
than you do or they could just be
getting it wrong because because they're
getting it wrong and and so in the end
there is never any substitute for doing
your own homework and applying your own
skeptical lens to something
so we have this powerful board
there a lot of them are very old
including
uh as i said the hundred-year-old george
schultz
uh
bill perry's 94 years old i think henry
kissinger is 98 years old
but i'm leading up to this tyler schultz
20 years old
tyler schultz what role did he play and
who was he and is that an interesting
thing to look at the old guys versus a
20 year old and what happened to this
company
right so it's a fascinating story and if
you want to know the
details of it you should either watch
alex gibney's film the inventor or read
john kerry rizz book bad blood because
that has all the really stunning details
of of of the story and how tyler who was
george salt schultz's grandson ended up
working at fairness because he was such
a believer on
what elizabeth was trying to do and
slowly started to realize that it was
all a fraud and i'm saying that and
probably more blunt language than than
than the than the the then the details
of the situation actually reflect but he
started to realize there were real
problems here and wow so when he tried
to go to his grandfather and when um the
company found out that he was the one
raising questions and had him um tailed
um fairness lawyer a very high-powered
lawyer called david boyes basically went
after um ty tyler and he you know
there's this moment that john kerry
recounts in his book where tyler is at
his uh has gone to george schultz to
basically say look i think you're on the
board of this company and you need to
get off this board they're real problems
here and he's ambushed by the company's
lawyers when he's when he's there uh
and it's just it is such a wonderful
saga of of of of whistleblowing and of
the dangers that can face the
whistleblower and of the bravery of a
lot of whistleblowers but but since the
details of this particular story really
belong to other people not not not to me
i'm just going to focus on the universal
kind of nature of this question which is
that
whistleblowers are really interesting
figures right and i think it takes some
element of
of being an outsider and so in tyler's
case he was really young and
and
because he was really young he was he
was able to ask questions that other
people who wanted to believe
weren't weren't willing to ask um um and
and so so it's
there's
that that is always a really interesting
component of these stories of business
gone wrong who is it that raises
questions and what enables them to see
things differently than everybody else
sees it because
a way of flipping the theranos story on
its on its head is that there were
whistleblowers there was tyler there was
a woman named erica chung i think there
were a couple of others but in the end
there actually were not that many
whistleblowers there were a lot of
people who worked at that company who
either kept their mouth shut or simply
didn't realize anything was anything was
wrong it so there's it's there's i'm i'm
not sure what the exact ratio of
whistleblowers to people who kept their
mouth shut and their heads down or
simply didn't see it before but it's you
know it's maybe five percent we're
whistleblowers and so most people are
biased toward belief they just they just
are and that's not necessarily a
terrible thing about the human species
but um but it but it is striking in
instances like this our guest is bethany
mclean on elizabeth holmes and theranos
in trying to figure out how elizabeth
holmes
uh
was found i mean she was
originally found guilty for under four
counts by the jury but in order to
figure all that out is it true then if
you just go back and reconstruct it that
tyler schultz
tipped off
mr carrero
of the wall street journal among others
that became a story and that started the
process
i'm looking and what i'm looking from
you
to tell us is how
you know if you're outside all this how
you can determine whether or not you
trust or believe in anything
yeah so i can answer the second part
better than than the first because i'm
not positive about the exact chain of
events i do not think it was tyler her
originally tipped off john kerry wrote i
think it was a
another health care reporter who worked
for a blog
who who who who noticed something in
who had come across some kind of
document that cast doubt about theranos
in another lawsuit and i think john
might have then stumbled on tyler by by
himself or perhaps in the course of his
investigation someone someone who
another source told him to call tyler
but i don't think the original um the
original tip-off um came from tyler um
but but i think the specifics of of of
this are are
less important than the generality which
is what you're you're getting at and
what what what what you're asking about
and
i i think i think it's hard um
you know
a lot of
a lot of stories that come to light
wouldn't happen but for some kind of
tip-off
so in my case with enron it was a short
seller named jim chanos who said who
called me and said hey i think something
doesn't make sense about this company's
numbers why don't you know why you
worked at goldman sachs you understand
the stuff why don't you take a closer
look at it
and so without that would i have ever
turned my eye to enron i don't i don't
think so um without this
call from this healthcare blog where
john kerry would have dug into fairness
maybe eventually it was a big enough
deal um maybe maybe he would have but
but but maybe not and so it it is
the having a source having someone who
says take a closer look at this is is
it's important and for people who
i think it's i think it's difficult i
think these these things can take on a
life of their own and and the belief
around them can become so cement-like
that it is almost hard to think well
maybe what if all of this isn't true
and i you can see that in so many so
many places you can see it in the
widespread collective belief in fairness
when it seems so obvious that you should
step back and say wait wait wait wait
wait how can a
woman in her 20s with no background in
technology and no background in medicine
be able to accomplish something that has
eluded
scientists and inventors for for for
decades does this doesn't and she won't
disclose any information about how
technology works and she doesn't have
audited financial statements does this
really make sense
and so in in in the end i think a lot of
these stories of business gone gone
wrong come down to uh
our willingness to believe in that thing
which after the fact seems so clearly
too good to be true and there's that
great old saying it's a great old cliche
if it seems too good to be true maybe
maybe it is and
and uh i think that's i think that's it
that's the basic law through which you
should you should see all kinds of
business opportunities think back on the
financial crisis
the whole thing was predicated on a
belief that mortgages made people who
clearly couldn't pay them back could
somehow through financial alchemy be
turned into securities that were as safe
as the credit of the united states and
you step back and you say no no no
that's that's not going to work there's
got to be a flaw in that somewhere
but but but the whole world was diluted
by that including you know back to
theranos's board and whether they could
have or should have seen it you had
figures like hank paulson and tim
geithner and ben bernanke saying in the
run-up to the financial crisis yeah
there's a little bit of a problem here
but it's contained it's not going to be
an issue
um
so
so it's astounding the extent to which
our willingness to believe can delude
not just some of us but but all of us
even people who really
know better
so
adding to this uh discussion and trying
to figure it all out the fact that when
she was
starting out
then i don't like the term but the media
the big television companies the big
magazines
all
put her on the cover
and called her one of the great women of
all time
and
she was made a member of the harvard
medical school board of fellows
in this process
walgreens bought the whole idea put it
in their stores the cleveland clinic was
involved again
where is the check and balance in all
this
right
so i think that raises a lot of really
good questions and unfortunately they
are
the same really good questions that get
raised every time
something like this happens with the
additional component here that what she
was doing directly affected people's
health and that
i think should be held to it to it to a
different standard although then again
when you think about what happened in
the financial crisis i mean losing your
house affects your health too it affects
all sorts of things so i i i don't i i
don't know but but these are these are
these are the these are the same
questions that that that occur time time
time and time again um
um
um and and i i i i'd like to believe
that a little bit of a skeptical
approach would would help i think when
it comes to the media in particular
you know it does reflect in some ways
the risk of being an apolo apologist for
the media it does reflect in some ways
the media's desire to find something to
celebrate for all that we are often
criticized for
looking for things that are wrong and
looking for headlines that terrify
people and talk about how everything is
going wrong in the world we're actually
often looking for good stories of people
succeeding against the odds and
in this case here was this woman in
male-dominated silicon valley who is
achieving these these awesome things
and i do think there is something good
about humanity's willingness to believe
in the media's desire to believe in the
media's desire to celebrate the
the thing that isn't like the rest um
that said
you know it it takes on a life of its
own and it does reflect a lack of
skepticism and a lack of willingness to
ask hard questions and then
it's really like a snowball rolling
downhill and becoming an avalanche once
there's a certain weight of stories that
say this woman is the greatest thing
since sliced bread um it it almost it
becomes like concrete again it becomes
this it becomes almost impossible to say
no no wait maybe she's not and it takes
a a different a different kind of mind
to to say that
jim chanes the short the well-known
short seller who was the one who tipped
me off to enron once said to me years
ago decades ago actually frighteningly
enough but he once said
it's really easy to find really smart
people who want to work for me obviously
but what's really difficult is finding
someone with a skeptical mindset who can
not only see things differently but
continue to see things differently even
when the rest of the world is telling
them they're they're they're wrong and i
think that is there's just there's just
a subset of people who are inclined to
look at the world through a skeptical
lens and it and it isn't most people and
i'm not sure that's a bad thing
let me talk about you for a while um
hibbing minnesota
yeah what was it like growing up in
hebbing and what did your parents do
so hipping is a small town about a
four-hour drive north of minneapolis-st
paul it's often the coldest spot in the
united states and it's
historically the main
source of employment there has been
taconite mining
which was converted into iron ore and
actually iron ore from the mines in
northern minnesota uh was the ingredient
i think something like 50 of the steel
that was used and that came out of the
united states for world war ii was a
huge huge industry back in the day
but the
economic underpinning of the town really
fell apart
in the eight seventies and eighties with
the collapse of the american steel
industry and really nothing nothing has
come along to to replace it um so it was
it was an interesting place to grow up
but because oh i should have said it's
also where bob dylan grew up a girl from
the north country um so it was an
interesting place to grow up in the
sense that it was a place where the
fundamental moorings of
that were being ripped out from
underneath it as i as i went through
high school i think something like 30 of
the time was on unemployment by the time
i was in high school because the minds
were shutting down and the major source
of employment was going away and kids
traditionally had graduated from high
school and followed their dads and gone
to work in the mines and that had
provided a really stable life and all of
that was was was disappearing um but the
place hadn't and i don't know if it
still has kind of adapted to that new
reality my high school was around 300
people in the graduating class and there
were two of us who left the state for
college
um that's it so my parents weren't from
there um my my dad was a doctor and
that's why he ended up moving there he
wanted to live in a small town in the
middle of nowhere where he could hunt
and fish and not be troubled by other
people so
that's that's where that's where we
ended up but my dad is actually
originally from mississippi um and my
mom is from connecticut so they were
they were outsiders to to the town
our guest is bethany mclean on elizabeth
homes and theranos
so how did what were you like in high
school and what led you to williams
college
so i i was um it was a smart kid who
pretended she wasn't smart because there
wasn't a lot of and it's you know an
interesting different discussion about
about
places in the country that don't
encourage academic achievement but the
hitting that i grew up in was was one of
those although i had two teachers
brothers in high school one named matt
bergen and one named dan bergen who were
my english and
math teachers who i think were the best
teachers any kid could could ask for
they were they were phenomenal um matt
diluted me into thinking i was good at
math and dan uh taught me how to write
so so so so with that um so with that
said um but i i so i i was basically a
smart kid who who pretended she wasn't
smart um and that was i think that
pretty much sums me up in high school
and i ended up at williams
not i'm not sure
i like to believe i would have had the
gumption to get myself to a good school
but i don't really know we're all
products of our environment and my
environment was not one that said leave
the state and go to a great college but
my parents weren't from hibbing as i
mentioned my mom had gone to smith and
was a big fan of the small
east coast liberal arts schools and my
parents basically said to me the entire
time i was going through school you are
going far away to college you're leaving
here and you're not coming back
and so
i it was just a given that i would apply
to the best college as i could and and
go and and not come back
are they still alive by the way your
parents
they are yeah they're back living in
mississippi
oh interesting
a couple of quotes that i want to feed
back to you and get your reaction i stay
outside the system
your quote
yeah so
so i do think that
what happens to a lot of journalists
there's that great and i've been
thinking about this a lot lately there's
that great cs lewis story the inner
circle the inner ring and it basically
says that once you're on the inside it
becomes you'll do anything you possibly
can to stay on the inside because the
warm glow of being on the inside and
instead of pushing your nose up against
the pain is just so overwhelmingly
wonderful that you'll do anything not
not to get kicked out of it and i think
there's a real danger in that
particularly for for journalists because
once you're on the inside and you're
getting invited to the right parties and
hanging out with ceos well it's a human
a very human to want to be liked and to
want their approval and generally the
way you get their approval is to go
along with what what they think and i
don't think people do that deliberately
i think it's just it's just human nature
it's the overton window right which has
become kind of an invoke thing lately
that wanting to
wanting to be reflected wanting to see
your reflection in a way that is that is
that it that that is um appealing to
those around you that makes you liked by
those that gets you approval from from
from those around you
and so i think making sure that you
don't think of yourself as an insider
and that you say um on the outside is
really important especially for
journalists and probably for investors
as well
you say i'm always a contrarian
i think that that is not always a good
thing it's true
generally when most people think one way
i want to think the other way it's it's
it's a very instinctive um reaction on
my part it's a reflex
it's not always a good thing in that if
you're contrarian for the sake of being
contrarian that's just as bad as
believing for the sake of being a
believer right i mean
you have to if you're inclined to be
contrarian then you have to question
your contrarianism as much as if you're
inclined to believe you have to question
your belief right uh because just not
liking something because everybody else
likes it is not in the end a very good
answer
quote bethany mclean i'm the opposite of
a motivational speaker
well i i've said that in speeches that
i've given because i like to talk about
business gone wrong and i've spent most
of the last 20 years covering these
stories of of business gone wrong but uh
which is so talking about how things go
wrong is sort of the opposite of a
motivational speaker right because
motivational speakers talk about how
things go right but i actually think
that you can learn a lot of lessons from
the stories of of how things go wrong in
the end maybe more lessons than you
learn from the stories of things going
right
are you writing a book now
i am my
longtime collaborator joe nocera he was
my editor at fortune and he edited the
smartest guys in the room and we
wrote all the devils are here our book
about the financial crisis together and
i are writing a book about the pandemic
um which is very very difficult and
complicated probably the hardest thing
i've tried to do
can you give us a sense of how you're
going at it
sir so what we're trying to do is sort
of a similar approach that we took and
all the devils are here where we went
back decades and looked at the
fundamental problems that helped create
the financial crisis and how they were
set in motion and who set them in motion
and why
and we're trying to do the same thing
here which is to look at the fundamental
problems in our economy the
pandemic either highlighted or
exacerbated everything from a capitalist
driven healthcare model to
outsourcing of essential manufacturing
let me go back to elizabeth holmes for a
moment and go back to the attempt to try
to find out what works and doesn't work
around keeping people honest
we talked about the media we've talked
about the board members of the
corporation
we haven't talked about the jurors in
the trial
yeah what's your take on the jurors and
are we served well by
that system of uh dealing with uh
criminal activity
i don't know i'll start with the last
one
it's a lot to ask 12 people without any
experience in financial
wrongdoing to
listen to testimony and the way in which
charges are brought in these kind of
cases doesn't necessarily line up with
our fundamental sense of right and wrong
and what i mean by that is that anyone
who read john kerry ris book or saw
alex's movie and thought about this
would say it is totally wrong for
elizabeth holmes to have promised her
blood tests could do things that they
couldn't do she endangered people's
health how how awful is is that of
course she could spend time in jail and
yet the jury didn't find her guilty on
that on that and part of that is because
you have to bring very specific charges
and say you can't just say generally
elizabeth holmes lied find her guilty or
not guilty you have to say she lied to
this patient in in this way and
sometimes when you boil charges down to
the specifics like that you you you
can't you can't prove that that that she
knew
and that speaks to not an issue with the
jury system necessarily but to a larger
issue to which there is no easy answer
in corporate america which is that
executives can insulate themselves from
wrongdoing by layers of lawyers and
accountants and underlings who then take
the fall when when things go wrong
because the executive can say well i
relied on their assurances that all of
this was was fine and then the executive
can't be found guilty even if that
person actually profited from all of the
wrongdoing that's part of the story of
the financial crisis angela mozilla the
former ceo of countrywide um
was was able to say i relied on on on my
underlings and they told me everything
everything was fine
and so that's that and
that
in a way you want it to be that way
because
no executive would would
we would really constrain risk-taking
and business in dangerous ways if
executives couldn't rely on the advice
of their lawyers and accountants and yet
it can also become fundamentally wrong
and i don't mean that in a legal way but
i mean in a moral way because the person
who makes the most money from
wrongdoing can also be the one who can't
be held accountable for it in the end
and that's i wrote about steve cohen in
sac capital which was a hedge fund that
was always rumored to be engaged in
insider trading that the department of
justice went after aggressively um um in
the early in the early teens and in the
end they were able to charge sac capital
itself with with fraud but they couldn't
get to steve cohen because they couldn't
prove that he knew because he was
insulated by these layers of underlings
and lawyers from from from any of the
wrongdoing that that took place at his
his fund so that that to me is a
fundamental tension in our in our system
and i don't i don't have a great
a great means of of resolving it but the
issue with the jurors another part of
the story with the jars and the
elizabeth holmes verdict gets back to
the op-ed i wrote and i beg and this
this this question of this line between
visionaries and fraudsters one of the
jurors said in an interview after after
the verdict that we believe that
elizabeth believed in her technology we
we think we think she believed in it
therefore we didn't find her guilty on
on these charges of defrauding patients
and it's this really interesting
question about about belief right and it
does it can get you off the hook with
criminal charges because you have to
show intent and if you believed that you
didn't have intent to defraud anybody
but in the larger sense the larger
ethical sense again again is is belief
and excuse i
struggled with this a lot when i was
writing about enron because i thought at
various times well just killing believed
in enron
and so how could he be an evil villain
the mastermind behind this this fraud if
if he believed and my my former
father-in-law
um i was i was telling him this over
dinner and i still remember him looking
at me and saying bethany the worst
crimes in human history that committed
by people who believed
and so alex gibney the filmmaker who
made the inventor about elizabeth holmes
and made the documentary the smartest
guys in the room and i have talked about
this question of belief is it an excuse
even if it is legally speaking or is
actually
belief in in
is is belief the greatest sin of them
all and
i think that's an interesting question
too
but i don't know
so i don't know in the end jury's our
juries in our legal system are set up to
rule on pretty narrow matters they're
not set up to say
i look at this situation and declare it
bad and and send this person to jail
um that's that's that's for the court of
public opinion and all of our all of our
morality and i guess in the end that's
probably
i concluded my new york times op-ed on
this note well if i were charged with a
crime i would want the jury just to look
at the individual facts in my case and i
didn't say this part of it but you're
making me think about this part as well
and determine what i did that was
actually against the law not just what i
did that they don't like
because in the end a legal system that
worked on people's individual senses of
outrage would be a pretty dangerous
decision and it may make us upset when
we're all outraged about elizabeth
holmes that she wasn't found guilty on
accounts on which would like her to be
guilty but if in the end that were you
up there you sure wouldn't want the
outrage of the crowd to determine your
your life right so
so so it's all it's complicated
this may be a small matter but what was
your reaction to the fact that elizabeth
holmes father worked for enron
you know not not much um there were a
lot of really good people who worked for
enron and a lot of people who either
weren't in a position to see wrongdoing
who worked in areas where there wasn't
any wrongdoing or who were in a position
to see wrongdoing but simply didn't see
it for some of these reasons that
we've we've talked about i've actually
often asked myself over the years if
when i was leaving goldman
in 1995 and you know going to executive
recruiters in an effort to say what
should i do next i wanted to be a
journalist but i had no training in
journalism just got lucky to get a job
at fortune and if i hadn't sent an
executive recruiter had said hey you
know there's this really innovative
energy company down in houston texas
called enron and you know they have an
interest in people with financial minds
and wouldn't you like to go talk to them
and if i'd ended up working at enron
back in the late 1990s would i have been
a believer or would i've been a skeptic
and of course i want to believe i would
have been a skeptic but the truth is i
don't i don't know the answer to that
our guest is bethany mclean on elizabeth
holmes and theranos another aspect of
the checks and balances is the
government you made a comment and it i
never never paid attention to this that
the
fda gets a lot of its money from the
people that they are regulating
uh
the pharma pharma uh pharmaceutical
companies and others the fda the sec the
justice department uh first of all if
you can tell us any more about the fda
and the money part of this
uh
what influence do you think that has on
the fda if that
and how much of their money do they get
from
the people that they regulate
well i knew the answer to this at one
point i like to blame the couple of
years of this pandemic and not just my
advancing age on the fact that i no
longer have facts at my fingertips but
it's it's under the um under the way in
which they approve they investigate new
drugs is mainly funded by the drug
companies themselves and there was a law
that was passed that enabled this this
this kind of funding
i'm not and i had stumbled on this and
learned about it because of the piece i
did for vanity fair on sackler family
and the opioid crisis where i think this
issue was was most pronounced but i'm
not sure in the end that the money is
the major problem i think it's the
biased hard belief toward wanting to be
liked particularly by people you think
are smart so there's the fda and people
come in and these executives present
them with with this amazing amazing data
and these drugs that seem powerful and
like they they they do something and
sometimes they get they get swayed by
that not not always and i actually think
the fda
does on balance a a really good job and
i do not want to sew
any skepticism about the fda
particularly
with with the vaccines right right right
now i'm very wary of that but yet you
you look back on the opioid crisis and
the fda could have for all the blame
that the sackler family gets the fda
could have shut that down by refusing to
approve these drugs and it was the fda's
unwillingness to listen to skeptics and
um
willingness to to believe um that that
allowed this to
to gain the momentum that that that it
did
and so i i think that's a problem
throughout large parts of our society
and i think it is there are large parts
of
our regulatory system
and i think it is less a question of
explicit corruption i give you money and
you give me this then it does and it is
kind of implicit corruption the
desire to be liked and the willingness
to believe in other people
seem to be like like you i think that
explains part of the
lack of prosecutions and the bailouts in
in the financial crisis was that it was
it was our crowd it was all people that
people in government knew and so they
looked at the big bank ceos and thought
well this isn't your fault this is you
know we all made a mistake um versus
enron which was these cowboys down in
houston texas it was easier to say
they're they're not us we're going to go
after them with everything the gov
everything all the might the government
can can muster
and so i think that that um i think that
that issue plays out plays out in in
many many ways
how many
or how often do you write for vanity
fair
not as much any anymore in part because
i i
i was hired by graden
carter and he left the magazine a few a
few years ago but also in part because
of this this book on on the pandemic
which is
difficult enough and
going to be overdue enough already
please i hope my publisher isn't
listening to this that i i
even though there must be
20 stories i would love to be working on
now i don't have the time to do anything
else so i have to get this before before
i do anything else but i think vanity
fair is still one of the few great
outlets remaining this will be what book
for you what number book
that will be the third big book but i
also wrote two mini books for a
publisher called columbia global reports
which is sponsored by columbia
university and which has had this idea
to do
short books on important topics that
weren't
getting covered by the mainstream press
um and
and but but that weren't necessarily um
fodder for for a long book
can you
make enough money doing what you're
doing to survive
oh it's it's tricky um vanity fair at
the time when i started there paid
enough money per story that if you wrote
three stories a year for the magazine
you were doing really well
that has changed dramatically
um i it is a constant and during these
years of the pandemic a lot of us made a
fair amount of money through speaking
and during these years pandemic that has
that has gone away people are
experimenting with lots of new models
like like sub stack but
i think as
a lot of us do as we get older i look
back on the early years of my career at
fortune magazine where i had a salary
and a good salary at that and health
insurance
and everything else and i think wow
what i would do for that again right
and the ability most importantly the
ability to and this is i mean i left
goldman sachs to become a journalist
because money making money is not the
most important thing to me and that for
better or worse has always been the case
and that's still the case
but but most importantly
working in that sort of environment
enabled me to take on stories like enron
that might that might have not panned
out but i didn't have to worry that oh
then i don't get paid whereas in the
current environment for people who are
freelancers if your story doesn't get
published you don't you don't get paid
so there's an incentive to choose pieces
and choose things to do that you know
are going to work
and i think i think that's problematic
do you do a podcast still
i do i had tried to do one on my own
which i really enjoyed
but i probably chose the wrong outlet
for it i i chose an outlet called
luminary that was subscription-backed
and subscriptions hadn't really taken
off at that time and i was an unknown
podcaster and so for me to try to get
people to pay for my podcast was was was
the wrong decision but i started doing a
podcast with a professor at the
university of chicago an economics
professor named luigi zingolis and we do
a podcast that touches on some of the
themes you and i have talked about today
because it's called capitalism and the
idea is to look at areas in which
capital capitalism is working in areas
in which it isn't working and the
intersection between
um capital capitalism and democracy and
it's it's really fun i think about a lot
of things that i wouldn't think about if
it weren't for doing this podcast so it
is intellectually expansive
our guest is bethany mclean on elizabeth
holmes and theranos